Bonjour. Aujourd'hui on va parler
de OnePlus mais surtout de son
nouveau téléphone le OnePlus 5.
Le OnePlus 5 vient de rencontrer
l'univers de la mode avec un OnePlus 5
Jean-Charles de Castelbajac.
Si vous me connaissez pas je m’appelle
Monsieur GRrr. Ma chaîne parle de
stratégie Youtube et des produits
d’influence qui vous aideront aller plus
loin dans votre vie digitale. Si vous
voulez être informés des
nouveaux produits et pouvoir améliorer
votre stratégie Youtube, je vous invite à
vous abonner à ma chaîne et activer la
cloche pour ne manquer aucune publication.
Quand l'univers de la mode
rencontre l'univers des smartphones,
de la téléphonie mobile ça donne
Callection. Callection c'est la rencontre
entre Jean-Charles de Castelbajac,
un créateur français reconnus
internationalement, et la marque OnePlus.
OnePlus a sorti il y a peu de temps
son OnePlus 5. Le OnePlus
5 a de nouvelles caractéristiques esthétiques
dans un univers
qui s'appelle Callection.
Callection offre un
nouveau design au OnePlus 5
avec le meilleur du OnePlus 5.
Tout ça avec l'univers graphique,
l'univers esthétique de Jean-Charles de
Castelbajac.
Si vous n'êtes pas passionné de
mode ce smartphone ne vous intéressera pas.
Si, par contre, vous êtes passionné de
mode,
si vous adorez la fashion week, si vous
êtes un grand passionné du travail de
Jean-Charles de Castelbajac,
ce smartphone est fait pour vous.
Avant de parler plus en détail de l’esthétique de
ce OnePlus 5 et de son univers,
je vais vous parler
des caractéristiques techniques du OnePlus 5.
Le OnePlus 5 a un écran 5,5 pouces 1080p fullHD Amoled.
Il a un double caméra à l'arrière de 16
mégapixels grand angle avec une
ouverture 1.7 et de 20 mégapixels
téléobjectif avec une ouverture de 2.6.
8Go de RAM et 128Go de mémoire.
Il a un Oxygen OS qui tourne sur un Android Nougat.
Un bluetooth 5.0. Il filme en 4k en 30 images par seconde
ou alors en FullHD en 60 images par seconde.
Il se recharge avec la technologie Dash
Charge OnePlus qui vous permet de
recharger votre téléphone pour une
journée complète d'utilisation en
seulement 30 minutes de charge.
Il a un processeur Qualcomm Snapdragon 835
octa core 10nm
cadencé jusqu'à 2,45 Ghz.
Il a un lecteur d'empreintes digitales.
Se l’USB-C. Une prise Jack
et une batterie de 3300 mAh.
Voilà pour la fiche
technique du OnePlus 5.
Ce n’est pas un nouveau téléphone donc si
vous connaissez déjà le OnePlus 5,
si vous vous intéressez à la téléphonie
mobile vous connaissez probablement les
caractéristiques techniques de ce
produit. Ce qui est vraiment nouveau
c'est son design qui est
extrêmement élégant. Comme je vous le
disais Callection c'est la rencontre
entre OnePlus et Jean-Charles de Castelbajac.
C’est un univers complet.
Il y a des sacs cabas, des
tee-shirts, des casquettes, des holster.
C’est un univers qui
se veut poétique et chromatique autour
de l’univers du OnePlus.
Jean-Charles de Castelbajac est extrêmement connectés.
Il est un grand utilisateur d’Instagram.
Donc il connait bien l’univers des smartphones.
L’idée de cette rencontre entre OnePlus
et Jean-Charles de Castelbajac
c’est d’avoir un produit qui sortent du lot
qui a une vraie esthétique.
En règle générale les smartphones sont beaux.
Ils sont en aluminium, en verre, avec des grands écrans
mais là c’est tout autre chose.
Il est créatif, avec des belles couleurs,
une nouvelle approche chromatique.
Si vous n'êtes pas féru de mode ce téléphone ne vous intéressera pas.
Mais si vous êtes féru une mode,
si vous adorez ça vous serez probablement
très intéressé par ce nouveau smartphone.
Ce produit est vraiment très élégant.
Le packaging est extrêmement bien réussi.
Si vous aimez l'univers de Jean-Charles de Castelbajac, vous ne pouvez pas passer à côté de ce smartphone.
Il sera disponible à partir du 2 octobre
au tarif de 559 euros
Mi-octobre tous les accessoires de la gamme Callection seront disponibles.
Voilà ce que l’on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur ce mariage de la mode et
de la téléphonie mobile. Dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez.
Est-ce que ce smartphone pourrait vous intéresser ?
Est-ce que vous seriez acheteur ?
Est-ce que vous avez déjà un OnePlus ?
Est-ce que vous pensez changer pour le OnePlus 5 Jean-Charles de Castelbajac.
Dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en commentaire.
Je vous invite à vous abonner à
ma chaîne car il y aura toujours plus de contenu
pour vous aider à réussir
votre stratégie Youtube et votre vie digitale.
Si vous avez des questions je
vous invite à me contacter sur Twitter
@MonsieurGRrr et avec le hashtag
#ASKMonsieurGRrr.
A  bientôt et d'ici là portez vous bien.
Bye !